dr. [ __ ] Ben Amin was born in Morocco
he was educated at Tel Aviv University
and Oxford University where he received
a PhD in history from 1982 to 1986 he
was head of the school of history at Tel
Aviv University and from 1987 to 1991 he
was Israel's ambassador to Spain dr. Ben
imme was elected to the Knesset in 1996
and in 1999 was appointed Minister of
Public Security in 2000 and 2001 he
served as Israel's Minister of Foreign
Affairs he's written several books in
English Spanish and Hebrew
his most recent his scars of war wounds
of peace which will be available in the
corridor after this talk you know more
people have won the Nobel Peace Prize
for bringing peace to the Middle East
than for any other cause the list
includes Ralph Bunche unworldly dot
Yasser Arafat yet chakra being Shimon
Peres and Jimmy Carter and yet within
the past few weeks critical events in
the Middle East have happened faster
than we can take them in a new political
party was formed in Israel Ariel Sharon
was incapacitated Hamas had great
success in the Palestinian elections and
a veritable firestorm erupted over
cartoons in a Danish newspaper we look
forward to this evening to gaining a
better understanding of the implication
of all of these events please join me in
welcoming dr. [ __ ] Ben on me
[Applause]
thank you for a very generous
introduction and for the privilege of
standing here before you in this place
and speaking about my book I trust that
you do not expect me to go into the
intricacies of Israeli politics or the
full details of a very protracted
conflict or the ups and downs of a peace
process that we know when it started
nobody knows when it will ever end
notwithstanding the Nobel Prizes as was
said before by the Vice President
nevertheless I would like to say a few
words on the book and then speak about
things that emerge out of the story of
the arab-israeli conflict and are more
related to current events because the
lecture in this part of the world needs
to be changing all the time so the
turmoil and the upheavals that accompany
the said history of the Middle East the
book that I have written in fact I
started by writing a book in Hebrew
which is a much more detailed history or
memoirs of the last two years of Bill
Clinton's presidency when the peace
process was at its latest stages and
which is when the Barak government where
I served plate-- played a role and when
I came to write a book in English it
occurred to me that that particular
chapter in which I was personally
involved needs to be put in a wider
context and I need to present to the
English reader an overview of the
Israeli conflict and the efforts at
peacemaking in a wider perspective so
the chapter where we intervened will be
perhaps better understood so this is the
essence of what I did in the English
edition of my book may I perhaps start
with the last the last sections of the
book which address the attempt to reach
a final settlement I think that and then
I will proceed to issues much more close
to current events I think that no
president before Bill Clinton dedicated
so much interest and and efforts in
trying to solve the israeli-palestinian
dispute in fact the arab-israeli dispute
as he did he was deeply involved in the
Syrian tract it was deeply involved
personally involved in in the
Palestinian tract he almost mult gauged
the the future or the image of his
presidency or for the sake of trying to
achieve lasting Israeli Arab peace and
he failed perhaps I should say all of us
failed because the President did his
very best I believe that all of us did
our very best but we failed and if I
have to to pinpoint where do I think the
reasons of our failure lie I would say
that they depend on to two central
issues one the what Isaiah Berlin used
to call the impersonal forces of history
there are reasons that are beyond human
capacity and they are of a structural
knight nature and then there are the
personal reasons the performance of
leaders of politicians at a given moment
the impersonal reasons are that the
israeli-palestinian conflict is
something that goes far beyond the real
estate sort of conflict that we had with
Arab are with other Arab states that
peace between Israel and Egypt was a
sort of real estate business
we had the Sinai Peninsula under
Israel's control in the wake of the
six-day war we pulled out from the Sinai
Peninsula Egypt recovered its
sovereignty in the Sinai Peninsula and
gave us peace very cold peace but have
an important piece nevertheless the same
problem we have with Syria there is a
problem of real estate I'm not going to
enter into the the reasons why Israel
went into the Golan Heights but we
occupied the Golan Heights this is the
reality and if we are in a position to
give away the Golan Heights we might
have some sort of cold peace I think
that if we get peace with Syria the
Syrians the Syrians will teach the
Egyptians what a cold peace really means
because the problem why
again Clinton and us failed to reach a
settlement with the Syrians is that for
the Syrian regime the identity of the
regime thus the the the solidity of the
regime was more important than
recovering land and they understood that
a peace with Israel the kind of peace
that Israel wanted that these pieces
that is accompanied by normalization
exchange of embassies Israeli flags in
Damascus Israeli tourists in Damascus
this is a kind of peace that might
undermine the solidity of the path
regime a regime that was and in a way
continues to be the last ideological
system regime in the Arab world
Mubarak's regime is not ideological it's
a sort of autocracy but not doesn't have
behind it in our ideology the pan-arab
and and failures of socialistic ideology
of the path regime and and the Hermetic
control of society by the system is
something that the Syrians were afraid
will be lost if they have a peace with
Israel there is a sort of connected
vessels between foreign policy and the
stability and domestic stability they
didn't want to put at risk domestic
stability and this is the reason not
because Israel was not ready to give
away the Golan Heights Rabine put a
deposit in Warren christopher's pocket
when he went to see Hafez al-assad and
say to him we are ready we are ready to
withdraw to the 1967 lines if we get
satisfaction with the security
arrangements and this was not enough for
Hafez al-assad this was the case of
Syria when it comes to the Palestinian
case as I said before it is not a real
estate issue it goes far beyond that
it's not land for peace because the
israeli-palestinian situation touches
upon other very sensitive issues memory
religion refuge ISM the ethos of refugee
ISM in Palestinian life holy places a
capital Jerusalem
now Sigmund Freud used the expression of
the narcissism of minor differences that
is 90 percent of the issues between
Israelis and Palestinians the so-called
real estate issues are solvable in fact
they were practically solved through the
clinton peace parameter ism came david
and beyond but the 10% that is the
narcissism of minor differences proved
to be unsolvable when it came to
refugees when it came to jerusalem holy
places i believe and i i trust that I'm
not being impartial I believe that we
went the extra mile even on these ten
percent of issues Israel agreed to the
clear-cut division of Jerusalem to
having two capitals in Jerusalem one
Arab that is one Palestinian and one
Israeli we agreed to something that was
unthinkable before we went into this
process that is full fledged
Palestinian sovereignty over Temple
Mount and we agreed to a practical
restitution of Palestinian control on
all of the territories ninety-seven
percent of the West Bank 100 percent of
Gaza plus a safe passage that was to
link Gaza was the West Bank so as to
make it a viable Palestinian state so in
that sense I believe that we went the
extra mile the policy
i if a Palestinian would debate here
with me I guess he would say a different
thing but this is the way history is
written the the the the the the truth of
the matter is that the
palestinian-israeli conflict or trying
to solve it is like trying to track the
genetic code of the arab-israeli dispute
perhaps even of the Jewish Muslim
dispute and it eluded us it eluded us
because it was so tough on the parties
so difficult to solve I think that
Arafat has the Lions the lion's share of
responsibility his personality his
psychology his inbred incapacity to take
decisions he once told me I am NOT a
negotiator I am a decision-maker in
retrospect I think that he was not a
decision-maker either it will always
shine having to take difficult decisions
and the reason brings us directly to the
issues that we have at stake today in
the Middle East the reason is this why
our fat was incapable of taking a
decision and they will immediately
explain why this brings us to the to the
center of our debate in the Middle East
today peace probably not only in the
Middle East is inevitably a divisive
enterprise war unites peace divides and
we all knew in Israel that if we reach a
settlement either in the goal on the
Golan Heights or in the West Bank that
is with the Palestinians we will be
leading to that peace a deeply divided
Israel
society but we trusted that Israeli
democracy the tools that we developed
over the years will solve this division
by parliamentary means by Democratic
means we will not have to fall into a
Civil War
this was the the confidence that brought
us to the peace process
now Arafat didn't develop any kind of
decent system of governance
he didn't develop the tools of
democratic discourse and he knew that if
he makes a historic compromise his
society will split and since he didn't
develop a system of majorities and
minorities he understood that this will
inevitably lead to a civil war but then
we used to tell him mr. Assad a peace
agreement that is acceptable to Hamas
cannot be acceptable to Israel you need
to confront Hamas just as mutatis
mutandis a peace agreement fully
endorsed by the Israeli far-right is
something that you cannot accept so you
have to confront the Hamas and the
Islamic Jihad preferably through
Democratic means and if not we are not
to blame that you you were incapable of
developing that the fundamentals of a
democratic discourse in your society and
we will have
to confront the settlers the fanatics
those who didn't really want to reach a
historic compromise with the
Palestinians and this is where we got
stuck in the incapacity of leaders to
take a decision which is inevitably
divisive which is inevitably divisive we
have been criticized by Palestinians and
others that we shouldn't have gone to
Camp David knowing as soon as we did our
efforts positions didn't we know people
say that the guy didn't want these or
that of course we knew but then you
always go with some degree of
uncertainty into peace negotiations
believing that at some point at some
point the leader will emerge and will
take a decision it was Charles de Gaulle
who said a great leader is somebody who
always has a surprise under his sleeve
we waited for that surprise I think that
Barack gave it we gave it by agreeing to
to split Jerusalem in the rest of it
that is just to give you an example of
such a surprise when during Camp David
won the peace with Egypt Menachem Begin
went to Egypt to Camp David on his way
he said that he wanted to buy a slice of
land a parcel of land in one of the
settlements in northern Sinai because he
wanted to build his house there now
Sadat could have said if this is the
position of begging I'm not going to
negotiate with him
but he nevertheless went there and the
leader drew a surprise out of his sleep
and this is the test of leadership that
was not met I believe by mr. Arafat let
me with your permission proceed now two
things that go beyond the the story of
my book but are emerging in a natural
way out of this story we so now how
Hamas the same commerce that was the
challenge that Arafat refused to face
that comes to power through democratic
elections I think that what I would like
to do now is to try and link if I may
the israeli-arab story with the wider
story of the Middle East that is of
immediate interest I believe to the
American public precisely because you
have an army now deployed in Iraq and
you have moved to a to a greater Middle
East sort of foreign policy I think that
has always been a synchrony between
regional processes and the small story
of Israelis and Arabs an example the
first Gulf War when President Bush
father went to the war you could see a
concept of connected vessels he said I'm
going to solve the Iraqi Kuwaiti
crisis but I will go immediately after
to try and solve the Israeli Arab
dispute he was capable of building an
international coalition most impressive
coalition
no such Coalition has ever been built by
Western statesmen after the Second World
War and the same coalition that fault
Iraq in the first Gulf War was the
coalition that went to Madrid to the
Madrid peace conference to start
launching the arab-israeli peace process
so there was there was a strategic
thought behind that particular war that
war wanted to redress the status quo in
Iraq Kuwait in the Gulf area he didn't
want to change regimes or to change the
balance of power between Iraq and Iran
and the others he didn't want to
reconstruct the Middle East he had much
more humble objectives the rationale
behind the Iraq war the one America is
engaged in now it's totally different
than that of the first Gulf War this is
a war whose aim is to reconstruct that
is to create instability as a policy in
order to build on the basis of this
instability a new construction a new
architecture I would call it if I may a
policy of constructive instability now
the problem with constructive
instability in that part of the world is
that you run the risk of creating
instability but not reaching the
constructive bit the constructive side
and this is exactly what we have today
we had certainties
of course immoral certainties Saddam
Hussein regimes that are autocratic and
they are and are incompetent and they
are corrupt what have you but stability
what we got in the wake of the invasion
of Iraq is instability upon which the
political architect needs to build a new
reality I am afraid we will not see that
reality this is new reality in the
foreseeable future where we are we are
stuck with the instability and therefore
it was very very difficult for the
President of the United States and his
coalition of the willing to to create
the concept of connected vessels say we
solve the the Iraqi situation and then
we proceed like Bush father to solve the
israeli-palestinian dispute you got
stuck in the instability and America
being the superpower and and what
Madeleine Albright used to call the
indispensable nation indeed it is an
indispensable nation it nevertheless is
incapable of dealing with more than one
crisis at a time and her hands are full
of work in Iraq and the israeli-arab
situation israeli-palestinian situation
is not a priority in this at this moment
the safety of American soldiers is a
priority the economic deficit the
financial deficits or you know better
than me what are the issues that that
concern American opinion right now so we
have we saw after the end of the peace
process with Bill Clinton a shift
the emphasis of America's foreign policy
from a concentration on the
israeli-palestinian issue to the wider
problems of the Middle East and this has
sort of ruled out any possibility of
having an israeli-palestinian peace when
when you had the the Iraq flare-up and
in the rest of it now we went into an
unstable situation and the American
discourse changed from one of weapons of
mass destruction to one of
democratization democratization was not
the initial objective of the war
it came later when weapons of mass
destruction were seen not to be there
and and and but then the problem with
and this is directly linked with a Hamas
situation the problem with
democratization is that you see in the
Arab world in the Muslim world in the
Arab world there is today no real choice
between dictatorship and democracy this
is a fallacy to believe that there is
such a choice the real choice is between
secular dictatorship and Islamic
democracy this is the real choice if you
conduct free elections real free
elections in Egypt it is not the liberal
opposition that will win the day but the
Muslim Brotherhood if you conduct in the
Palestinian territories as indeed you
did we did no they did free elections
you don't get a liberal opposition
coming to office you get the Hamas and
for all practical purposes for all
practical purposes what America did in
Iraq is to depose a bloodthirsty secular
dictator and create by omission or Bible
necessity practically an Islamic
Republic the Shiites if you look at the
Constitution it has many religious
ingredients and chapters and and and the
cheap Shiite majority is there to make
the difference many of the problems of
irrational problems military problems
faced by America in Iraq are the result
of the fact that what you have there
today is a civil war between the Sunnis
and the Shiites in Iraq there's a total
disintegration of a society with the
religious element being paramount
another example in the early 90s years
before the Iraq war Algeria Algeria was
a country that was liberated from France
40 years ago 50 years ago and and with a
revolutionary regime secular
revolutionary regime the FLN that after
30 years of revolution there was not
enough couscous for everybody in in
Algeria and then they went the
revolution of the couscous there well
there was a moment of of social
upheavals because there was there was a
shortage of couscous and and then they
went to free elections and the result
was that the Islamic Front won the
election
the Islamic fundamentalist want
elections this was the alternative air
between the dictatorship of the FLN and
the other option was Islamic democracy
so the the Islamist won the elections
and immediately after the army took over
said no we want democracy but we want to
know in advance who is going to be
elected so I didn't work it didn't work
and this is a fallacy that I am puzzled
really that the great nation like
America should have eluded these nuance
in in in in this complicated Middle East
there is no western-style democracy in
the Middle East right now as a feasible
foreseeable option option and you cannot
punish we have a problem here because on
the one hand the leaders in the Middle
East are all pro-western but the masses
are anti Western how do you bridge the
gap can you can you really develop a
sophisticated democracy if you do not
have a middle class a sizable middle
class and you do not have proper
economic growth and you do not have
investment in the in the educational
system this is the problem democracy is
not a project democracy is a process and
it is a long one so we come today to the
situation where we have a Hamas regime
in in the Palestinian territories well
what would this mean for the peace
process
I saw articles all over the press
including in America mourning mourning
the death of the peace process because
Hamas came
to power the truth of the matter is that
the peace process was dead since 2001
there was not much of a peace process
the part is Israel isn't Palestinians
after the collapse of the peace process
in 2001 went back in the time machine to
the core of the conflict what we had in
the last five six years is not a peace
process but war and unilateral
disengagement and this is not a peace
process this is very important because
it reduces the friction between the
parties the fact that you withdraw from
part of the territory you create a more
sort of rational border that's okay but
it's not a peace process and to say that
Hamas is signaling the end of the peace
process is simply not true
not not the case another reflection that
occurs to me in the wake of Hamas
victory is that I simply refused to
share the nostalgia that I see
everywhere with Arafat and the PLO what
was so good in the in the in the
previous situation did we have stability
did we have a peace process did we have
a capacity of the parties to assume
difficult decisions what we had is a
Palestinian Authority that was built on
the image on the chaotic image of Arafat
corrupt incompetent the other day it was
discovered by by the attorney the
Palestinian attorney general that there
was an embezzlement of billions of
dollars you know I can understand the
President of Congo when he steals funds
why because presumably they have all
kind of natural resources this is money
they don't get from out
but these are donations the Palestinians
like the Israelis do not have natural
resources we don't have water we don't
have oil we don't have gas this is the
promised land and and and the the land
of milk and honey milk we have in honey
we have so I think that what what you
see there is an embezzlement of funds
that come from from donor countries and
this was the PLO this was Fatah I want
to be very clear I think there is a sort
of poetic justice in the victory of
Hamas and this is even I would I would
dare I would venture to say that this is
a celebration of democracy to the credit
of the Palestinian people who else
should have they elected in this
situation a liberal opposition that does
not exist they elected those were the
puritans world we were the politically
virgin
we were untarnished and those who in
their opinion faced the Israeli occupier
in a very forceful way I fail to see why
this is not understood now can something
be done with Hamas the last thing I want
in this presentation is to appeal to you
as advocating the case of Hamas I'm just
trying to follow Oscar Wilde's dictum
when he said that the difference between
civilization and barbarity is the nuance
and there are nuances that we
to introduce into the debate and not put
everything in the same basket otherwise
we not know how to address these
situations of course they they engage in
terrorist practices inadmissible
in war or in peace I am NOT going to
condone that obviously but let us see
what is this organization that we have
to deal with now Hamas is not al Qaeda
al Qaeda is engaged in a global effort
against Western civilization Hamas has
terrorist practices that need to be
denounced that need to stop but that are
aimed to a political purpose that is
clearly defined and that is to have the
entire Palestine without the State of
Israel preferably this is a certain
difference that may lead and has already
started to lead Hamas to wake rising in
the existence of the State of Israel in
the early 90s
Hamas invented the concept of temporary
settlement with the Jewish state they
continued not to recognize Israel but
they say we can reach with these people
a temporary settlement precisely because
we do not recognize them precisely
because we do not believe that a final
settlement with the Jewish state is is
called for we can have a temporary
settlement the PLO obsessed as it was
with the endgame refused to engage
in the process of an interim settlement
Hamas precisely because they don't see
the feasibility of negotiating with
Israel and endgame they spoke in the 90s
about a temporary settlement with Israel
second reflection on Hamas in June 2003
Hamas declared a unilateral truce with
Israel not directly because there were
no negotiation but he said we stopped
suicide attacks against Israel and the
rest of it one of the reasons obviously
was the repression the responses of
Israel the targeted killings of the of
the Hamas leaders this one this was one
of the reasons that brought them to
declare the truth admittedly but was
another reason and the second reason
which is the more important in my view
if we wanted to understand current
reality is that Abu Mazen the new
Palestinian president changed the
policies of his predecessor Arafat who
discarded Hamas from the political game
our first system of government was one
of divide and rule mood Abbas precisely
because of his weakness and his lack of
proficiency I would say in in political
manipulation integrated the Hamas into
the political system in a GoSee hit with
Hamas he reached agreement with Hamas he
did it through the
Christian's and Hamas felt that they
were being integrated into the political
system and this was another reason for
the truth the conclusion is that we have
here the case of an organization whose
world of religious imagery is deeply
located within a political context and
precisely because they are not only
precisely because they are not only a
military organization they are opened to
transformation and yesterday one of the
leaders I think is the main leader not
knowledgeable of the entire structure of
Hamas an MN called much al whom Israel
tried to eliminate in the 90s and failed
when it was in in in Amman
Masha al made a very interesting
declaration yesterday he said we Hamas
recognize all the agreements that were
signed between Israel and the
Palestinian Authority very interesting
now I I don't think that we are close to
the days of the Messiah with these
people not at all the only thing I'm
trying to say is that they were elected
democratically the international
community needs to impose on them all
the necessary conditions in terms of end
of terrorism and reorganizing the State
of Israel there's no doubt about it
there should be no mistake about it but
on the other hand we'll have to see how
we move with the new rulers in Gaza and
Ramallah
to a new phase in these peace process I
need to put it in quotation in quotation
marks what is clear is that the entire
diplomatic ad
that was built by the quartet that is
the United States Russia the EU and the
UN which is the the Alliance for peace
in the Middle East the entire peace
edifice has collapsed you cannot work on
the basis of the roadmap anymore
in fact I am on record and I wrote
several articles in the British press on
that that the roadmap was born dead now
it is official now even Secretary Rice
recognizes that the roadmap needs to be
shelved there is no longer any roadmap
now what is the new peace paradigm if we
want to move ahead the new peace
paradigm in my modest opinion needs to
build on the will of the Israelis and
this is the essence of Sharon's legacy
to pursue the politics of this
engagement here you have a political
system that says we can't reach a
settlement or maybe we don't want to
reach a final settlement but we are
ready to withdraw from the bulk of the
territories unilaterally and this is a
move towards the end of occupation it's
not peace but it is better than
maintaining this degree of friction and
this impossible Bosniak style map of
settlements in Palestinian territories
we say let us dismantle them let us
create rational borders between us and
the Palestinians let us make Palestinian
life more decent and let us restitute
some honor and dignity to the
Palestinians because they have had
the toughest years since 1967 during
there is the last Intifada but the
problem is that if you disengage from
Gaza which is a compact area with very
well-defined borders borders that have
never been in dispute this is one thing
and you could see how smooth or how
relatively smooth was the disengagement
one thing is there is Gaza
another is to disengage from the West
Bank which is much more complicated map
you need there a degree of subtle and
sophisticated coordination that you need
a partner to coordinate with because the
lines are not that clear not that
compact and you need some sort of
coordination will we be able to
coordinate these with a with the Hamas
government difficult to say but perhaps
we can coordinate this with the quartet
with the international community that is
through a third party
back-to-back Palestinians and Israel is
not necessarily negotiating we were
unable to do it in Gaza with the PLO how
will will be a we will we be able to do
it with with Hamas in the West Bank I
have my doubts this is where perhaps I
need to admit before going into that
that I don't see the international will
but this is the only solution that seems
to me reasonable that is that Israel
will withdraw as it says in the
political platform of the parties
running for election now in Israel it
says that that they want to pursue the
politics of unit unilateral
disengagement and since you cannot
coordinating with the become us
but given the fact that Hamas is ready
to assume the concept of a temporary
settlement a third party needs to take
over the territories and have a
peacekeeping force I can see a long-term
interim agreement until the next
generation not biological generation
political generation the next political
generation will try to solve the problem
always with the help of the
international community basically of the
United States the parties between
themselves will not reach a final
settlement it will always have to be
brokered by the United States and they
will always have to be nursed into
assuming the decisions through then the
international community so maybe we will
have to go into this new paradigm if
somebody has a better paradigm is
obviously invited to write articles
about it and to advocate it I didn't
think of this paradigm today I always
believed to be more correct not always
in the wake of the collapse of the peace
process in 2001 my conclusion was that
our failure to reach a settlement was
not the result of some technicalities
that we needed a glitch here and the
kvetch there but our failure was a
defining moment it was something much
more profound and that the parties for
one reason or another are unable to
reconcile themselves to each other's
fundamental requirements and therefore a
sort of an international solution will
have to be conceived but for America to
go forceful
into this new paradigm it will have a
guess to feel itself more secure in the
wider Middle East and bring some sort of
stability to Iraq and start removing the
pressure in that country when will this
happen I believe that America is now in
the in the job of trying to define what
are the conditions that can justify
disengagement these will if I may have
to be sort of minimal conditions of a
near democracy a loose federal system in
Iraq some sort of semblance of stability
to allow America to disengage I hope she
will find the will and the energy to
engage again in the israeli-arab story
because I do not really believe that
that set story can come to her to a
happy conclusion without the
intervention or the the central role of
what modern Albright called this
indispensable nation thank you very much
[Applause]
yes of course
you know one thing that interests me is
that if you're speaking about the lack
of concentration of the US right now on
the israeli-palestinian problem it seems
to me that more and more however you
keep hearing from the Arab world that
the u.s. is only concentrated on Israel
and that the whole move into Iraq and
the Middle East is because of Israel can
you discuss that okay I think that the
you're right in in depicting America's
image in the Arab world as a state or
the power that is too friendly
exceedingly friendly to the State of
Israel but I I did I did not mean that
this that this is the problem the
problem is that America is not engaged
in the peace process it's engaged in in
in supporting the State of Israel these
are two different things
and declaration by President Bush the
other day is I think is almost
unprecedented when he said a couple of
days ago that all perhaps more that
Israel the United States will will line
up with Israel will stand with Israel
against Iran I don't remember the exact
the exact phrasing of the sentence it
was I think a historic declaration by
the president and these reinforces what
you said that the image in the Arab
world is indeed that America is too much
of a friend of Israel this is the this
is the the perception but what what
perhaps I should say is that the the the
two countries that benefited most from
the Iraq war and this is to prove that
this was not necessarily a war conducted
this discourse I didn't see this
discourse very much in America I saw it
in Europe that the entire wall was done
by the neoconservatives who are friends
of Likud in Israel of Benjamin Netanyahu
and
and they did it to serve the cause of of
Israel but the the two countries that
benefited most from the war
strategically speaking are Israel and
Iran so can somebody say that the war
was was conducted for the sake of Iran I
mean this is a byproduct this is not the
purpose this is the pipe product of an
American policy that had an ideological
drive to change the Middle East
democratize etcetera etcetera but the
pipe product was indeed that it served
strategically Israel I really think that
today and I can I can mention in this
context the recent declaration by by Dan
elutes the the Israeli chief of staff
who say that Israel has never had a
better strategic position III said it
before him but I am NOT the chief of
staff and and the the strategic
condition is is very good right now yeah
a rogue Iraqi regime has been has been
discarded that's been ruled out a
formidable Arab American army is
deployed along the borders of Iran we
have Syria that is being disciplined as
when and pulled out from Lebanon we have
privileged relations with the Turks with
the 13 in Turkey and very interesting
relations with India so I think that
statistically speaking
Israel has benefited they lost some of
it is not directly related to the Iraq
war and when it comes to the Iranians
you can see an improvement in the
strategic position Iraq that was the
natural enemy that wound the iraq-iran
war in the 80s has been eliminated as
Shiite majority has taken over in Iraq
which is very close to the Shiite
Iranian state in fact Ali Sistani
is more an Iranian than an Iraqi the she
the Shiite leader of
of Iraq is more Iranian than Iraqi and
and and the the strategic space for Iran
is the Gulf area and it is there that
they feel to very much freer from any
kind of pressure so I think that this is
what I will answer here that indeed
there are historic relations between
Israel and the United States very
intimate relations
I believe they serve the cause of the
two countries I think they have also in
my view not only a strategic and
political dimension they have a profound
moral dimension and and but to say that
the war was conducted for the sake of
Israel I think is a gross miss
misperception and misconception I could
evening thank you for coming to New York
City to speak on my questions thank you
for coming to New York City to speak all
right my first question what did you say
sir I said thank you
okay perhaps without the microphone the
microphone it will work better
yes there's a question I have I'd like
to know do you think it's a two-part
question do you think that the boycott
of Hamas is going to be effective and
number two a friend of mine who's about
mid 70s sent me an email asking me if I
believed that Israel was entitled to the
land it stole from the Palestinians and
I I answered him I don't believe in
violence do you think that it's a moot
point it's a moot point whether Israel
in quotes stole the land okay and as to
the first question whether Hamas
we'll be conducive to to some sort of
accommodation with international
community the the signals so far as I
try to say are not entirely negative and
they'll give you some examples for
example the the insistence of Hamas to
have a national coalition with Fatah
with those of the old regime is the
expression in my view of the willingness
to - not to frighten too much and to
create a sort of balance that may be
acceptable by the international
community
I really see signals in the declaration
yesterday by by Khalid Marshall when he
say that he recognizes all the
agreements that were signed between
Israel the Palestinian Authority these
are all reflections of an intention to
change their ways toward degree to what
extent difficult to say what I don't
believe will happen is that the
international community will say now
we'll give you the money that is due to
the Palestinians
if you tomorrow recognize the State of
Israel and and all practices of
terrorism I think they will end the
practices of terrorism without making a
declaration at least in the immediate
future but they will not recognize the
State of Israel in my view unless
recognition of the State of Israel is
something that can be interpreted as as
indirect for example khalid mosh i'll
can tell you that by saying that he
recognizes all the agreements that were
signed by israel and the palestinian
authority he recognizes the state of
israel it doesn't make have to make a
ceremonial declaration so i think that
they will try to serve on the
complicated situation for them because
they face a terrible dilemma they are
ostracized internationally
Fattah doesn't want to join the
coalition they they have won elections
they did not expect to win because they
didn't want to face this dilemma of
having to recognize Israel they wanted
to have a militant Palestinian
Parliament well where they will control
the policies from outside maintain their
political virginity and their Puritanism
not be tarnished by power but they won
and now they have a problem and and and
this is where they are trying to find to
square the circle in my view as to the
second question you see I think that
except for Jesus Christ everybody else
was born in sin and this includes
nations all nations were born through
war sometimes atrocities expulsion this
is the history of mankind ernest renan
French philosopher defined once a nation
as a group of people that lie
collectively about their past so we all
have our own mythologies and this is how
nations and nationalism is created and I
don't feel any complex of inferiority
with the way other nations came to be in
terms of stealing or not stealing we
came back to a land we were expelled
from where we wrote the Bible where our
entire identity as a nation and the
religion was formed and we went back
there and I recognize and they say that
in my book very clearly that during the
War of Independence they were committed
atrocities and expulsion and this is
very very sad that it should have
happened
I don't know however if clue is stat
hood could be restituted without just by
conviction by saying okay we came back
we want to be here there was a
resistance in the Rose War and our life
was on the verge of not existing and we
won the day and we have a state and
today the the task of this generation
this is where the Israel is of my
generation feel a deep sense of failure
that we are bequeathing to our children
a conflict we should have been able to
solve this is the real tragedy in this
story we need to try and minimize the
damage that we caused to each other the
Palestinians are a nation that has been
punished by history sometimes more by
the Arab states than by the State of
Israel do you really think that in 1948
the Arab states invaded Palestine in
order to create a Palestinian state as
won 8-1 resolution of the General
Assembly had it not at all they came to
annex Palestine to their state they
didn't want to create a Palestinian
state they never wanted so many in
justices were created in that part of
the world what we need to do is our best
to minimize the damage so that the
Palestinians can have a viable decent
Palestinian sovereignty so that they can
live in prosperity in prosperity and
preferably in good governance
yes I'm wondering why you're taking
encouragement from temporary settlements
and ceasefires and recognition of past
treaties when the Islamists have this
notion of hudna that they'll accept the
treaty until the time is right for them
and then they can accomplish what they
want and Hamas is position has always
been no you know no Jews in the land
they want to get rid of the Jews and
they're also bringing armaments into
Gaza now so they're arming themselves
they're waiting for their opportune time
yeah well III do I do agree what you say
but I don't think it contradicts my my
essential thesis and I'll try to explain
this I never thought that an arab side
and this even include if I may a country
like Egypt that by recognizing the State
of Israel and signing a peace agreement
with Israel this is the reflection of
assuming morally the right of the Jews
to have a state in that in that part of
the world it is simply recognizing a
reality that is there I do not expect
that a temporary agreement with with
Hamas or a final agreement with the PLO
for that matter would have meant that
the intimate dream to do away with the
existence of a Jewish state would
evaporate it will have to take time you
see I think it was author amosmoss who
say in this exactly in this context that
we are not here about making love we are
about making peace and and the Arab
states around us will not will not love
in the sense that that you say I mean
not simply love you say they want to
destroy as well but they will not love
the State of Israel but they will
recognize a reality and either in a
temporary agreement or in a final
agreement the the major guarantee for
for that kind of agreement would have to
be a strong Jewish state otherwise it
may not be able to to guarantee the
peace or the agreement so I think that
this is going to be not a celestial
peace not then the sort of new Middle
East that was envisioned in the past but
something much more modest much more
realistic you know the the clue to the
popularity of Ariel Sharon and and the
reason why he became the embodiment of
the national consensus in Israel in
recent years is that he he abandoned all
the rhetoric all the lofty dreams about
end of conflict and the new Middle East
so the Israelis do do agree with the
premise of what you say and when they
say okay let us go either for a
temporary or a final agreement they they
don't they don't do that in in a way
that that they take lightly
the hidden intentions of the other side
button though always have to be on guard
inevitably inevitably
during the can be david negotiation what
you know today and you have represent
presented it in this wonderful lecture
for instance that arafat wouldn't have
any chance of succeed because of the
civil war they don't have a basis for
democracy and what you just said now
that israel should get an incremental
peace but not it did not end game would
you conduct the negotiation differently
or not conduct at all what's it's a very
tough question really i mean i think
that the the main point where i differed
with with prime minister Barak was that
not in Camp David really I think that in
Camp David all of us believe that there
will come a point where where the the
attitude of Arafat will change and none
of us really knew in advance that this
pattern of behavior of the Palestinian
leader will persist to the very end even
beyond Camp David in Taba
but where I think we should have frankly
changed our attitude was when the
Intifada erupted I think that if you if
we would have stopped then the
negotiations we might have still be in
office today we committed a mistake that
that was inherited in a way from its hoc
Rabine Robina invented the concept
he sort of paraphrased a sentence that
was used by ben-gurion during the Second
World War when he said that we will
fight the
they're in the white the white poke the
white white paper wife it eluded me in
this particular moment okay the the
white paper as if there was no Hitler
and we will fight Hitler F if there was
no white paper Robin said we will pursue
negotiations as if there was no
terrorism and we will fight terrorism as
if there was no peace process I think it
was wrong and the Israeli public didn't
accept it and we committed exactly the
same mistake there was a sort of
addiction to the process and the belief
that around the corner
a surprise will come and the decision
will be taken and this is what we say
this was our major mistake had we known
it in advance that this is going to be
the pattern I guess we should have taken
a different course
can you make it two or one and a half
okay thank you
first question is of historic interest
perhaps according to Dennis Ross a map
was actually submitted to Arafat that
came David now there was a spate over
the world spate of articles published by
one of Clinton's aides who participated
that came David I forget his name
Oh claimed that there was absolutely no
such map and Arafat believed was pretty
much in the dark as to what exactly the
offer was would you be kind enough to
elucidate on this point was there a map
was it clear and what exactly was being
offered offered let's say by Israel but
what was Israel willing to accept when
when they were talking about withdrawing
from the West Bank okay what particular
borders were they discussing the
outline of what was put on the table in
CHEM david amounts to the following in
territorial terms what was said is that
the Palestinians will get 91 percent of
the West Bank and a hundred percent of
Gaza in the Clinton parameters six month
later the position was 97 percent of the
West Bank but in Camp David we spoke
about 91 percent with a land swap that
president Arafat said to President
Clinton say as to the degree of land
swaps I trust you mr. president you
decide this was the position in income
David when it comes to Jerusalem the
proposition was as follows it did not
divide the city in a clear-cut way as it
was later divided in the Clinton
parameters it only said that there will
be there will be different degrees of
Palestinian control on the Arab
neighborhoods those in the outer circle
of the city will be under full
Palestinian sovereignty those closer to
the Holy Basin will have a sort of
autonomy under Palestinian control not
full sovereignty whereas the old city
which is a one kilometer square the old
city which is the core the core of the
problem will be divided in two the
Jewish and the Armenian Quarter will be
in the hands of Israel and the Christian
and and the Muslim Quarter will be in
the hands of the Palestinians when it
comes to Temple Mount the call of the
core of the problem what it said is that
the Palestinians will have not full
sovereignty but what the president
called
custodianship which is exactly what King
Abdullah in in Saudi Arabia has on the
holy Muslim shrines custodianship
without mentioning sovereignty this was
the package that was put more or less on
the table if I may the key word here is
contiguity for a while following the
conference the claim was that there was
absolutely no contiguity there was some
something similar to Canton's which was
somehow very threat barely tied together
okay
the Palestinians used the term bond to
stuns not countenance bond to stuns they
use the term that this was a state of
Bantu stance in the initial Israeli
proposals those that we worked on during
the secret talks that we held with the
Palestinians in Eilat and then in Sweden
and different parts this is a peace
process that somebody wants coined the
expression that joined the peace process
see the world we went where once it was
the Navy now it is the peace process
because we met Palestinians all over the
planet and so in these early meetings
the Palestinians are right to say that
the proposals that were put on the table
had these very tricky maps of Canton's
and Bantustans and problems serious
problems of contiguity but in Camp David
this was not the case and less so in the
Clinton parameters of December 2000
how can 91% be a problem I mean if if it
were
60% 50% of the land you can see okay
there you will have a problem of of
contiguity but with 91% all questions of
contiguity were supposed to be solved
let alone when you go to the 97% which
is what was proposed later on there
there was no problem with Bantustans of
or contiguity but our fad to his very
last day continued to insist that he
never got a proposal that that gave
contiguity to the palestinian state this
was simply not the truth it was true in
the early stages of the negotiations not
in Camp David and after in my book you
will see the map of the Clinton
parameters the I have four maps attached
in the book and and in the fourth map I
I didn't see that map anywhere else this
is a map I constructed really based on
the Clinton parameter this is the first
place that I ever saw the map appearing
and it appears in the book and you you
charge yourself if this is not
contiguous this is the map of the
Clinton parameters please join me in
thanking dr. Benavidez book is in the
be in the lobby to talk
[Applause]